les bombardements long transpercer et
coupé en deux un immeuble résidentiel au
nord de kiev dévasté par des dizaines
d'explosions
symbole d'un conflit qui s'enlise se
transforme en guerre totale n'épargnant
pas les civils
à quelques mètres cette maison en
flammes vient d'être touché par une
bombe
des occupants et les voisins tentent de
sauver quelques habits du mobilier
cet homme ne peut retenir sa détresse
je laisse ici toute ma vie toute ma vie
est partie en flammes
contrairement aux premiers jours plus
aucun bâtiment n'est un abri les russes
ont même bombardé cette école primaire
des combats toujours plus féroce sur
tous les fronts à kharkhiv mario paul
moreau janka ou tchernihiv
là les dégâts sont énormes
tout un quartier a été soufflées par les
explosions
les civils sont aussi prises au piège
par les échanges de tirs dans cette
voiture derrière ce pare-brise criblé de
balles
le corps de la conductrice tuée sur le
coup
il y avait à peu près de 30 militaires
qui sont allés vers le centre du village
et 70 autres vers les fermes collectives
et là la fusillade a commencé
au nord les cortèges russe progresse
très lentement mais au sud l'avancé est
plus marquée mario paul est encerclée et
les russes ont conquis la ville de
carson
ambiance désertique
filmé par cet habitant nom ou le social
la rue est quasi désert ya seulement
quelques personnes amassées devant les
épiceries au toc toc toc toc sur la
place centrale des camions humanitaires
ils distribuent de la nourriture mais
l'ambiance est électrique
face au ministère russe des ukrainiens
qui crient leur colère contre
l'occupation